[Music]
foreign
ERS you hear out here and the things
that you go through out here and the
commitment level on different levels of
acting and stand up and you know how for
some people this is a flash in the pan
and they you see them three years later
they don't even do this no more that
they're doing something completely
different now because this was too hard
or this is for [__] or you got to be
gay to be in Hollywood you know you
don't need comics and kind of common
[__] gone and you see them years
later are you still out there
and then yeah I'm still out here [__]
doing nothing
in the sun lifting [__] kettlebells
while you're out here sweating your
[__] life or I got insurance I got a
[__] pension I wasn't supposed to
have things like that you heard my
[__] story you know what I'm saying
so I don't know yeah I understand where
you're coming from I don't give a [__]
if you get heat no and there's some
solid people out here it's not the
people but it's maybe it's because I I
I've met a lot of people that aren't in
the entertainment business that are very
solid oh yeah when I go to towns like
Whittier and all those places to do
comedy I need some [__] stuff do they
have La Pride like from coming from
Boston and stuff I always like when it
comes to but then again you know when
you go to a Laker game it's more to be
seen
that's what people understand about out
here it's but that's going on with the
Knicks too God forbid you don't have the
first three rows in the Nick game and
people can't see you on TV and you're
drinking a beer yeah and you're cheering
and you're young you know I I never saw
what that's all about I'd rather stay
home I'd rather be on some [__] I'd
rather be at on a [__] couch with you
smoking a joint beautiful onion talking
about stupidity about a podcast or
something that's been the way with me
constantly yeah it's it's really
surprising when people go I want to go
into the green room or I want to hang
with you guys after a show listen since
I've known Rhoden I don't do nothing
they used to go to strip clubs and then
as the years they progressed they go to
a bar then we go back to the hotel and
then you start doing less and less
things you know there's no [__] party
here it's amazing how it's I said that
in Tempe we're like we're sitting there
after the show and everyone was just
quiet in the room and and like after the
show you're like you're hungry and I was
like and you know we just all went back
to our rooms and I was like this isn't
like I thought it was gonna be a big
party and and and go and hang out till
five in the morning the comedy show yeah
that's the [__] party that the party
is doing the show and then going home
like I've said a thousand times for
years I would consider those things real
party and after a comedy should I go
party and guess what by Saturday night
you're paying 22 to come see me and I'm
sucking yeah I'm sucking because I'm
tired of my my [__] mind's not
straight and that's what happened to me
for [__] years man what do you think
people just get funny no they put all
the elements together maybe they were
funny and they couldn't put a joke
together maybe I could put a joke
together but the dedication of my
commitment yeah there's so many things
then comes a point where one day you get
sick and tired of being sick and tired
and you put five of The Seven Elements
together and you move a little forward
yeah and that's what you helped me do
that's what we did you understand me but
that stood that the whole uh thing of it
and that's with boxing that's what
happened with Rob Robbie Lawler you've
been around for 12 [__] years knock
your [__] God getting beat up
getting submitted comes back to the UFC
the guy's got a fire in his eye okay he
just lost the last fight for a
championship round but he's 32 years old
he's not going anywhere he learned from
that fight he learned the same way how
when Johnny Hendricks lost to GSP he
learned yeah I'm sorry I'm using the MMA
things but you learn you learn as you go
go across and even if you lose trying
some now you know when you attack it
again you know what to look out for yeah
you know there's people that try to
escape from Cuba all the time and maybe
the the the the [__] float won't last
past 50 miles now they gotta go back to
the Drone but oh we gotta wear more glue
over this so you know but it's you know
you're not going to get everything the
first time and and today I learned today
I was thinking about it today how big
experience was because I when I got home
I was thinking about it we I didn't
really panic when this happened the
biggest thing I complained about those
jobs I had
but the big you learn that stuff is
gonna happen and if you freak out if if
you have if you overreact and it hurts
you on one level on
at least for me if I overreact and I
start getting worked up and and I start
playing with everything I'm not gonna
see like when you lose something at your
house I always run around and pull
everything apart and throw everything
around you're sick you're like
you relax relax
you breathe and you retrace your steps
and you'll find your [__] keys it's
amazing especially even with cell phones
oh yeah cell phones I walked out of cars
and go what the [__] right there
it really is amazing so you know people
want to try [__] and it doesn't succeed
it takes years
to be a good comic the way it takes
years to be a good fighter it takes
years to be a good writer but that's the
thing like you probably even even when
you were sucking 15 years ago you
learned something at one show that comes
up now and you're like oh I'm not going
to be freaked out about yeah
I remember being in Jacksonville Florida
and going out into the audience and
seeing I used to judge the audience
I used to judge the [__] audience and
it used to judge me and I'd bomb
so do you understand me I gotta go out
there and I go look at all those older
people at White hair they're not gonna
like my material I just lost
I just got hit with the biggest punch
which is I lost before I even went on
that yeah and then I go I won't look at
them and it was just so many things I
would eat [__] because I wouldn't do my
material I'd speed through the joke I
wouldn't take my time
and now I see old people you saw what
happened in Tempe yeah those old people
that were there and I went out there and
saw them and I go I'm going to pull it
back and I go [__] no I'm gonna open up
this [__] valve because you can
always
close the valve but you can't open it
once you you follow him saying to you
it's like acting when you go to an
audition and you walk in sometimes if
you go in and the character is loud and
you go in there the first time he's
gonna get mad directly because you're
not loud enough or you're not uh your
energy isn't that high okay I can't do
nothing with you if your energy is high
coming in I could push it backwards yeah
but if you're not you follow the the
state of mind we're talking about a late
night church of what's Happening Now
Monday April 21st where's Tony Bennett
[__] sucker there's no Tony Bennett
tonight what happened you're slipping
this is what I'm talking about
what was it it's coming hold on it's
coming it's not it's supposed to be
[__] lined up and prepared I'm sorry
we came up late today the audio but who
the [__] I'm not sorry [__] happens I
hope you [__] stayed up Monday
is Monday we got till midnight to put
this together I'm still gonna fire you
up you're still gonna go out there on
Tuesday and wanna stab [__] the
neck it's the church with the two out
where's the water
foreign
nice
two two see how he does it what's going
on Lee turn that [__] off what's going
on I already little candle for the old
lady I put some glasses of water out
you know me I get it though I've done
out of the [__] ways what's going on
with you
I just [__]
and I I know we've talked about this a
lot but
the weight thing for me is it's always
been there like I've never what'd you do
with that pot roast I know you ate them
no it's in my car
um yeah you might as well just dump it
because your car well no because so
here's like it's
I I everyone I think everyone has their
addiction sort of thing and for me it's
it I think part of it's an addiction I
think most of it's laziness honestly but
ever ever since like like you and Terry
it must just get to a point after a
bunch of years where you don't go out as
much but ever since I started going out
okay I put the weight back on and I just
luckily I have I think the thing that
some people don't have like when you go
on TV and you see like the to a thousand
pound person
is I luckily when I get to a certain
point I'm like okay I gotta bring this
back I'm trust me I I shouldn't let it
get to this point
but it's uh luckily I I feel like I have
that in my brain where I'm I I don't
think I could get to a thousand pounds I
probably could but it's just uh so I've
been working on that I uh I've talked to
people about joining a gym
I would love to get a bike but the
people around here are crazy so I don't
I don't know what I'm gonna do I I don't
start with walking
it all starts what is it it's not going
to go if you can't walk you're not gonna
go there generally if you don't walk
you're not gonna go to the [__] gym
just trust me if you can't get yourself
to walk what's going to get you to get
you in a car to drive to a [__] gym
to be around people who look like David
and Goliath to [__] work out yeah you
got to start walking and that's what I'm
saying to you I haven't been pushing it
I've been telling you go for a walk
for the last two months what have I been
telling you no and it's cool
[__] about what's going on or where
you're busy you get out of here at nine
o'clock the car ain't going nowhere walk
to the 10th planet
go read the [__] wall and walk back
that's it this isn't hard today with my
bad knee I was sitting there I wrote I
emailed I'm sitting there I'm like what
the [__] am I gonna do
I sat outside I tried to write a joke
I'm like what the [__] am I gonna do I
went upstairs I took two [__] baby
aspirins it was about 12 15. I went
downstairs I rotated my knees in all
directions I did these hip things I
[__] stressed a little bit and I said
[__] it you know the knee is going to
hurt whether or not I work out or not
yeah I might as well work it out a
little bit I'm not gonna jump [__]
ladders and be Johnny Goomba but I'm
gonna work at the blood go I did 10 sets
of swings and I did [__] five sets of
six sets of cleaning jerks I got nice
and sweaty took me 35 minutes I picked
up a 45 and a 35 walked 50 yards and 50
yards back and I put the weights in the
car and I was done for the day yeah and
I don't you know what I didn't eat sugar
today
you know I hate that that [__]
chocolate bar and I ate two of those
things with 10 calories a piece I don't
drink soda no more I was telling my wife
to add it the only way not to give your
child to stop your child from drinking
soda is by not drinking soda in front of
them yeah it's crazy and I tell you what
I love North Bergen I love where I'm
from
I love a majority of the people I grew
up with but I knew something that always
killed me there's something that killed
me about people there's two things
I can't follow a white trash
I can't tolerate the Mind thought the
mindset of white trash
they grow up
they get a job and they play the hand
down they don't even play the handout
you know I was surrounded by white trash
in North Bergen
uh
good people you know I'm not saying
nothing bad about them good
God-fearing Americans you know that's
not it but I always felt that their
dreams were too small in fact I don't
think they had [__] dreams I see that
more now that I'm out here I didn't see
it when you see what I'm saying to you
and that bothered the [__] out of me I
call White Trash to people a person who
doesn't have a dream somebody who comes
up to me and says guess what the Allman
Brothers are at the Atlantic City you
know we're gonna party out and I look at
them and I see how excited they get it
brings pain to my heart yeah it brings
that much pain to my heart you know that
that little like the The Allman Brothers
aren't even together no more like that I
think they retired but not even like the
original band right you know it's like
you were telling me before about Pink
Floyd like 18 people have hit me up
already and so you excited about Pink
Floyd you want me to tell the truth not
at all I haven't even [__] thought
about it I don't give a [__] you know I
really don't give a [__] if they put a
new album out or not will I buy it who
the [__] knows I might put it on but I
don't want to see that stuff it's like
you were saying to me do you want to go
see Aerosmith and Slash at the Coliseum
or whatever are you [__] crazy are
you [__] crazy you know I saw
Aerosmith When Aerosmith was Aerosmith
and they were never even Aerosmith
because anybody who knows when you went
to see Aerosmith went to heroin they
were horrendously bad I don't hate to
see this band it was a superpower
and they were horrendously bad because
of the drugs and I don't know how they
are now people you know nobody's gonna
pay 55 for a ticket
the concert sucked yeah do you know what
I'm saying it's against their whole
thing they're not going to pay a hundred
dollars especially now a concert's 300
they're not gonna come back and go man
that sucked no they're gonna come back
but back to the white trash thing I
always felt they had no dreams
like even in high school you'd say
what's going on nothing man I can't wait
for my father to get me this job in this
Warehouse I'm going to get 18 an hour
and that was it yeah they don't go on
vacation they never leave New Jersey
they wouldn't even dream of [__]
leaving New Jersey that little car that
they belong to you know they get excited
about the weirdest [__] things in my
hometown North Bergen there's a
you know at this point now there's maybe
four [__] bars that these young kids
could go to
you know but who gives a [__] you're 10
minutes away from the greatest city in
the world
I mean that's the advantage of being
from North Bergen New Jersey but you get
people from North Bergen and on Friday
night I'll go to the [__] Moose Club
and this is like a bunch of people that
are all built like I am
they're as big as I am and they go down
there and they talk about high school
football and they're stuck in that time
warp yeah like that's the white trash
I'm talking about they're stuck in this
[__] time warp of their mind that
there's no dreaming there's no nothing
they just coexist with life that works
for a lot of people that wasn't going to
work for me are you jealous at all
because I have some I never had a huge I
had a couple friends in high school but
not like a group of like six or seven
I'll go on Facebook now and I'll see
that they're still hanging out and
they're at parties and I hated all of
them I don't want to be there but like
maybe 10 of me is jealous that they
still like hang out and most of me
thinks it's stupid but part of me is
like I was like oh that'd be nice to
still have friends from the high school
but I don't I talked to one kid from
high school that's it
I'm very lonely mm-hmm but I'm very
lonely because I want to be
I'm very lonely at times because I want
to be
do you follow me yeah in my mind those
kids I grew up with that was the best
that got for me
that was the best it would ever be for
me and I never tried to duplicate that
even hanging out with comedians if I
hung out with four comedians the
top-notch comedians in the country they
wouldn't give me as much humor
as I did when I grew up with those guys
and I know there's going in right
because they're not trying they worked
on timing everything was based on timing
it was life they reacted to life and
they were very funny about doing it I
can't uh take back
half those things and I'm not
glamorizing that life or living in the
past
but
those type of friends I grew up with in
North that'll never happen again I love
you and you're a good kid
I like the Agostino and
I just know that it was a different
situation and it required a different
type of friendship you know the cops are
never going to come knocking on your
dongle is Joey and you're gonna giggle
in their face and get the [__] out of my
face and slam the door that's never
going to happen in this lifetime yeah
three people I'm Gonna Knock in your
door and say where's your buddy Joey
Diaz he robbed me you know and you're
gonna go I haven't seen him in two weeks
[__] you if we don't have our money
we're gonna beat the [__] out of you two
in three days that takes a certain type
of friend somebody would say [__] you
I'll tell you where he is right now yeah
these [__] are like you said
what you better [__] them choose your
words [__] wisely
you gotta choose your [__] words
wisely you're not gonna do [__] to me do
you know it's it was different
was a different time yeah but I'm very
lonely you know in that aspect because I
could go to Hollywood improv and goof
around
with a bunch of people that at the end
of the week who gives a [__] right you
know I could go to The Comedy Store and
again oh my God that's such a funny joke
gives a [__] when I get my car you're
gonna talk about how I do blow and now
you know whatever the [__] mind [__] you
may give yourself for why not you're
achieving your goals and why not you're
doing what the [__] you're doing
so it was just really weird I just uh he
asked me when I found out and I knew a
year after my mother died I was getting
the [__] out of there and it wasn't
because I hated the people or you know
like I said white trash to me or people
that you see them and you know you're
gonna see him in 30 years and nothing
changed and they're happy they're happy
about it I always wanted more yeah I
always wanted a challenge every day you
know I wanted to get challenged every
day when I wake up in the morning I want
a different type of day you know people
hit me up all the time they hit us up
all the time hey man we have a song for
the church guess what take your [__]
song and shove it up your [__] ass I
don't want to hear your [__] song I'm
gonna tell you why because if you know
anything about me I can't do the same
[__] twice every day so why would I want
to hear your [__] song every [__]
day I appreciate that you took the time
and writing it and I love you to death
but push your [__] magic elsewhere
[__] sucker you know last night some
dude was trying to get me to play Warren
Zevon
you see that conversation no you told me
about it he's like hey can you play my
buddy shot himself this week can you
play Warren Zevon listen to the first
three [__] words of this song I Gotta
tell you something I would have shot
myself too I would have shot myself in
the [__] head if I had to listen to
that [__] who's the other one you hate
at the beginning
I [__] hate that dude that's the dude
that every party you go to someone yeah
let's put on Zeppelin and oh no no no
let's put on I forget what the [__] I
forget who it was but you hated him too
he sounds like he's taking his [__] all
the time he's America's sweetheart they
all love him you know the Gentile Nation
you know anybody who wears the [__]
the hat with Sinatra to the side they
all [__] love that guy you know [__]
you I'll put [__] anything on compares
to that [__] every day that I got it
sounds like he's taking a [__] Rick
Ramos license oh really well yeah Rick
Ramos he's trying to turn me out to him
I heard him and then I call regular Rick
you're not [__] serious you're not
[__] serious are you
the [__] is that guy's name hey someone
tweet at me if you remember I forget
what the [__] is that guy's name I can't
stand that [__]
yeah my buddy died can you play this
song I'll get the [__] no wonder he died
I [__] died too and he's like well if
you can't play that song you can play
this song I'm not gonna play that
[__] song either that Tom Waits Tom
Waits oh Jesus Christ thank you and Jack
truth that is the [__] worst that
[__] is the [__] worst garbage I have
ever listened to in my life that is
[__] worse at least that white trash
in North Bergen to listen to at least
the people I grew up listen to real
[__] music you weren't allowed to
fake the funk like you were not allowed
to fake the funk at all and come up with
like to be cute in front of some girl
you know what I'm saying like yeah I
don't know you know put on Springsteen
like you never heard that [__] but
somebody would stab you in the [__]
neck there's a Sabbath house [__]
get your [__] together oh my God but it
was uh
it's just weird like that to see those
type of people
that you just knew like and I love them
I'm not saying nothing bad about them
that was their prerogative prerogative
but they're going to settle and I just
didn't want to settle Lee you know yeah
was that your mindset behind leaving or
was your mindset yeah I just I've always
wanted I don't it probably was but maybe
maybe I'm not smart enough to realize it
yet because it's still it's still only a
few years ago
um it moved fastly I know and but I
always thought I'll tell you this I
always thought it'd be New York even
after I was out here for a few months
interning and I went back I started
being New York and then I had a job in
LA and I just I came out and now it's
now it's home but I always thought it
would be New York
you know and I always hated that also
that other mind that other small-minded
thing about the guy
you know like the guy like a mayor like
the mayor in North Bergen he's a [__]
putz you know I know when he was like an
assistant principal at one of that
Lincoln School the guys are [__]
putts but if you go to North Bergenline
the guy walks in the room people like oh
I never had respect for that mindset
either yeah [__] that [__] that
[__] puts his little pants on one leg
at a time that's why I can never be like
I saw Julia serving I saw Richard Gere
when I was a kid I didn't give a [__]
you know I would go up to him and shake
their hand like I didn't say nothing to
Richard Gere at a club and Julia serving
with my [__] Idol pretty much growing
up
because if your alarm goes off they're
going to be there if you shoot somebody
in the bar they're going to be there and
clean it up first
what happened here this guy pulled the
gun lead you sure you put a fake gun in
his hand boom call the cops you paid now
what's gonna happen is but
every once some of those guys go they
retire
and you got a young guy who thinks he's
slick and he'll come in one night and
throw a beat normally
and then say how he wants this much
money and then come in there once a
month
get a couple drinks on the house
embarrass my mom and embarrass the
customers
what the [__] do you do
you go to the other guys and you talk to
him
and you move him you got cops like that
in the 60s and 70s something would
always happen with those [__] cops
really yeah when I was a kid something
would always happen with those guys
because you had people that just wanted
to do business
and they wanted to keep it low-key
they just wanted to put their kids
through college
and they'd help you off they really did
help you out like I said if you if
somebody broke your glass they were
there first and have somebody that
bought up your glass
if your alarm went off and some humped
down the corners alarm went off they
came to your lawn some people at home
disagreeing with me now but I'm telling
you what I saw as a young man where the
etiquette was in the 60s and the 70s do
you ever see like a business say no or
did your mom I know that there were some
businesses that probably said no I don't
know what happened to them whatever I
know that
also if uh the ABC was out checking IDs
or whatever these city cops came in and
told you their schedule also if the DEA
was in town shaking down Spanish bars
these city cops told you your schedule
when the DEA comes to town they have to
stay at a hotel
they don't stand it they stay in a fancy
hotel and they put it under the DEA
credit card people at the hotel that
work at the hotel get the word out the
DEA is in town
that's it everybody knows to close up
shop to slow down a little bit these
cops would help you out so if somebody
was watching your bar they'd tell you
somebody's watching your bar this is a
full-time coverage I don't know how it
is now there's drugs involved there's
cracking love there's weapon tomorrow I
don't know I really don't know I'm away
from that
I don't know how I know I don't know how
to think because in movies those cops
are always like the bad cops always
though it's crooked and and but the way
you describe it copies don't make that
much money
and everybody everybody in life gets
jaded at their job yeah some people are
listening to this right now going Joey
we don't allow we want you to hear the
other side of this
no matter what type of job you do you're
a working [__] stiff till the end I'm
a working stiff Lee would have been a
working stiff as an editor you know you
would have got promoted finally as an
editor and you're still 28. and when do
you retire 65. so unless you open up
your own business you're a [__]
working staff 40 years so for 40 years
you're a working stiff okay now I don't
know if this becomes the same for cops
I'm gonna break it down for you guys and
bring you know everybody here at some
point at 38 goes what the [__] am I
doing
I just saw a bill by mistake they pay me
15 bucks an hour they charge 55 for me
and I'm only getting 15 and yeah 15 goes
to insurance and state taxes but they're
still getting 25 dollars for me for
labor-wise I'm making 15 an hour this is
what I'll do till I'm [__] 65. you
know whatever everybody gets jaded at
their work somebody gets a promotion you
find out some idiot makes more than you
you know my wife is a [__] hard
worker
my wife doesn't believe in the theft
when she was a waitress and you know she
got she didn't want to work at the store
no more then she went to [__]
Starbucks I would talk to my wife my
wife is such a gentile she doesn't
believe in fact everything is by the
[__] penny you know the other day she
found that the chiropractors clipped us
for 65 bucks she goes I read somewhere
that all medical bills are off they're
all wrong
I was off of my insurance she went
through all my bills found out that I
was over called my insurance got my
insurance bump to level one my wife is a
[__] Hawk when it comes to this she
works she works she worked boom she got
pregnant one day 10 days 10 years on the
job they pay for a pregnancy she wasn't
doing nothing she [__] was a slim jim
Magoo that [__] cried for a week but
she went to work after eight weeks she
went to work and she drove home with her
tits leaking
you know from the milk and she'd feed
mercy and you know I would see the
anguish in her face and I pleaded with
her that quit she told me she couldn't
quit
in about three weeks later she came home
one day and she said that they gave her
a raise they gave like a 1.3 raise
she was never so embarrassed in her life
that she's out worked three of the
[__] people and then they took the
girl that's the baby's godmother and she
had been there for 10 12 years 15 years
and instead of hiring her they got
somebody from the outside
and she started thinking about how
you know these people really don't give
a [__] that that's why I got into comedy
and blah blah blah and she I was very
smart and that was part of it I was
jaded I didn't want to work for people
no more I was sick and tired I didn't
want to be that night in the [__]
fight you know
and I saw my wife get jaded and she goes
I'm quitting and she didn't do it for
like two months and then she started
going back part time after three days
she came home and she goes I can't do it
no more I hate those [__] people
same thing happens when you're a cop
same thing happens when you truly
believe in your heart that you're
helping people
you really believe in your heart that
you're helping people
and all of a sudden you help somebody
you're calling ambulance and they get up
and try to shoot you
you go to these houses these people
don't give a [__] about you because
you're a cop you're always the enemy no
matter what they tell you
I grew up believing in police officers I
really did I grew up believing and I
still do even as a criminal even as a
criminal I still believe in police
officers I still believe that they do
good but then again you're going to get
guys that jaded then since they work
long hours they get jaded in their
personal lives
a wisely you know most of these cops
have a few marriages they get drunk they
don't tell I can't come home and tell
you I come home at night what'd you do
today I shot a movie with Dean Kane what
did you guys do well today's uh we got
chased by a dog we ran up the stairs and
chased the dog and then we ran down and
they chased us and there's another scene
where he puts a string out and we both
jump over and we both fall I can't tell
my wife that
I saved the kid in the dumpster today
and the kid was half burnt
and this is an awesome I tend to do
drugs also when I arrest somebody one
day and
they have three baggies of meth but only
turned into
and I do a little bit of it you know God
knows with an office's mind is thinking
yeah I I'm not sticking up for the guy
who shot the 12 year olds in Cleveland
no I'm not sticking up the hands up I'm
not sticking up for Ferguson I'm just
telling you that before we accuse we
have to think of both sides about it and
I hate to get into these conversations
because there'll always be critics of
this but it's true yeah [__] true I
was on both sides and I was very lucky I
never drew on a cup
you know take a gun out
I was never that [__] crazy right
I was I didn't have that much of a Death
Wish for years I thought I did
but I really didn't
and a lot of [__] up [__] could happen
I drive home on the tent I drive home on
the 101 Lane so do you how many times
you go to [__] Compton you're a white
kid in Compton right for a year you
drove the [__] a bad name but you're
coming home one night they say pull this
guy over he's here for drug activity
yeah they pull you out of a [__] car
where's the drugs I'm not here for drugs
they smack you when you go home how are
you going to feel about the cops you
ain't gonna hate them you're gonna still
feel believing I hate them but you're
going to believe in them anymore are you
ever gonna doubt you know it's it's just
we get traded in so many different
[__] levels buddy yeah so I just had
a cousin who had to quit being a uh a
social worker because he's done it for
like two years and he was just like I
can't do it anymore
every week There's a new kid who gets
beat up or it just it was terrible
I mean all you could do is uh live your
life the right way yeah and pray to God
you never get accused of something
wrongly pray to God you're not the wrong
place at the wrong [__] time right
you know so how's the movie going by the
way
the movie is
first off I didn't want to do this
[__] movie I had the worst attitude
about it
because what they do is they do uh
sagalog budget movies they give you a
little taste to the back end
and uh you get limited visibility you go
on ABC Family or ion or something like
that you know
uh the first one I gave my blood on this
I fell down
that was the beginnings of my pains when
I started hurting my knee and [__] first
time if you watch them 400 pounds oh no
easy and I'm falling on the floor I'm
running upstairs and uh
then like the second and third one you
know we were talking about something
like that I don't like doing a lot of
[__] once I do it a few times I move on
you know and I always thought I wanted
to move on from this
when they called this time I had a date
in Chicago but I had another movie that
it called
pushing that back to March or something
so I got stuck with this you know I
didn't want to do it uh
never [__] they've been great the whole
time one day that
the air conditioning broke on the
trailer the second day but besides that
this is what I do believe
and I enjoy breaking my year up I enjoy
I'm very fortunate that I don't have to
go on the road every week and carry my
[__] luggage and be in Philly right
now you know be in some place that's
going to get snow and be get caught
there on Sunday I've worked for that you
know and I like that I get lucky from
time to time and somebody calls me and
for a week I just avoid doing stand-up I
don't even think about it you don't miss
it no I went on stage Saturday night
okay but I I didn't have to sure I miss
it but it's great to know I don't have
to do it that for a week I could just go
home and go to sleep and just do this
movie do you think maybe your stand-up
would get better from like taking a
little bit of time off everything needs
a week off yeah everything always could
use a week off from time to time I'm not
saying all the [__] time
but everything a hook ain't gonna fall
asleep sucking your dick if she's doing
a good job you know what I'm saying
she's working that [__] jaw her whole
head's involved her eyes are blinking
it's a bad situation please say it don't
look at me like I'm [__] up have you
ever had a hooker fall asleep on you no
I'm just saying what the [__] I never
had a [__] hook or fall asleep on me
no I had one local experience and that
was it I bail on that [__] thing
local experience
so what are you doing Christmas then
we were going to try to do a podcast at
six o'clock
Christmas Eve Wednesday just to fulfill
what we do for you people
and we started thinking about it I gotta
thank you so much we do a podcast at six
I mean it's not in the east coast I
gotta be honest with you people if you
guys are watching this podcast
Christmas Eve at nine o'clock on the
East Coast you got problems it's time
for you to [__] look deep within you
you know I I know some people get lonely
and some people need a laugh or whatever
but you know I don't want you people
doing this I want you people going out
and enjoying touching people get the
[__] out of the house get the [__] off
that [__] computer go get out get
some [__] air you [__] smell
something smell some ass go do something
no sitting here because I'm depressed
because my grandfather got hit by a
truck man who gives a [__] [__] Grandpa
he left you the [__] car that's all
that matters you're alive and kicking
get out there breathe that's all I ask
you so Lee and I decide we'll do it
early so maybe you can watch it uh
Wednesday at lunchtime if you're on the
East Coast sit smoke a [__] number
maybe listen to Led Zeppelin three dig
with me and Lee got the same maybe we'll
get a guess maybe we'll have my boy call
I got the U the second part I watch a
part of it I DVR it and I got it at the
house both times I've DVR it like last
time I deviated was [__] women's
volleyball I almost killed somebody
today uh but no it's is Christmas Even
important to you because for my entire
childhood I went to this Italian
family's house for Christmas Eve and
then now we're on with your family your
dad my dad worked with him and we went
every year that a guy dressed up a sin
every year it was great
um and then Italian food and now Paula
her mom and her cousin
uh Christmas Eve is more important than
Christmas Day I I just don't I don't
know anything about it so they do
presents of Christmas Eve they do
tamales I don't know
I'm Jewish it doesn't what do you do
when you grow so you went over to this
guy these people's house Christmas yep
and then what did you guys do you go
home and stare at each other there's no
tree at your [__] house because I'm
Jewish we had Hanukkah so there's no
[__] gifts when you went back to your
house no they all give oh my God they
gave us so many gifts they're like a
richer Italian family they we went home
with more gifts than we got at Hanukkah
sometimes
they loved us it was great it was a
shout out if you're in the on the east
coast of the lombardos they have a
nightclub and stuff but technically
where my bar mitzvah was but uh no it
was great I um I was always a little bit
jealous of Christmas like I went my
cousin his ex-wife is Christian and I
went over there once when the kids were
really young and the kids fell asleep on
the floor under the Christmas tree like
in the middle of opening their presents
because they just had like so many
presents they just couldn't handle it
and I was a little bit jealous because I
I my parents were well off when I was
growing up I had a bunch of presents at
Hanukkah but it's still probably two
presents a night maybe three presents a
night which adds a full [__] presents
I don't know it adds up to be a lost
crime no but I'm just saying underneath
the tree [__] Jews you spoil each
other aren't you [__] yeah it's not
always like PS4s it's like a small thing
when you're a kid socks a t-shirt your
favorite pajamas yeah GI Joe's hat yeah
you know maybe one time
you know what what does it mean
I mean what does Christmas eve mean I
wasn't meaning you're raised that it
means that you
go somewhere with your family or good
friends just in case you don't have a
family and then you get together and
you maybe exchange gifts you maybe don't
maybe three years are broke it's a tough
time of year but everybody understands
not about the present it's just that
feeling you know you're reading you know
I've had the best Christmases when I've
been broke the best Christmas Eve really
and I have and I've had a good
Christmases when I had money or shitty
ones because
you didn't do nothing with it you know
how long did it take you to like start
celebrating after your mom passed away
wow
I just remember coming from Cuba I
remember
I'm not going to sit here and say I'm my
first person I [__] you I remember
on Christmas like after when I was like
six or seven I was maybe six and I still
believed in Santa Claus
and they took me to the bar which I
never had gone to in those days a lot
I would go maybe once a month in those
days
and when I got back the gifts were under
the tree and it was they were all with
me anybody who could have done that it
was a [__] trick so even though my
friends told me there was no Santa Claus
I was like you guys don't know maybe you
guys are dumb [__] there's a
Cuban Santa Claus that showed up in my
house so that was the only Christmas I
really cherished that I really believe
that you still remember it yeah I
remember that particular one is on 205
West 88th Street they moved the dinner
table and they put the tree against that
wall
I still remember how that those lights
used to flash against that wall you know
I still remember how important Christmas
was to my mother and it's also the 7th
of January
that's on the three kings
so on that date you get cash so the
Cuban Christmas runs basically from the
17th
to the to the uh
to the seventh very ironically I you
guys have heard me talk about saying
that did I talk about this the other day
that that whole Cuban thing happened on
Saint Lazaro's birthday
um I was so high I don't think so well
yeah the whole human thing happened on
Saint Lazarus birth that's why it's very
important Cubans I I was goofing with
John salami the other day my buddy he
said that he was calling people
the last week or so and he wasn't
getting a response from people for
business and I said John you're 45 years
old tell me you're not that [__]
stupid
Gentiles don't they give up
after the [__] 15th it's done white
people done and I don't blame you you
know black people are broke they don't
give a [__] you know it ain't over till
it's [__] over but white people have
a list you know Gentiles have a list and
they plan it out they're going to Nick's
house and they're going to give Nick and
a kiss under the [__] Green Tree
whatever a mistletoe what other [__]
a little nugget yeah that you know when
they just plan all this [__] out you
know so uh
you know when you're a Savage you just
go by
what are we talking about anyway about
well I think you're talking about like
Christmases like yeah so the Cuban stuff
that so after the 15th people people
bring that you're not gonna answer your
phone you're gonna take on new projects
it's like no I need eight days and I'm
out of here I'm just killing eight days
so I'm I'm killing files I'm stapling
[__] I'm cleaning my desk you know you
just yeah you don't want to do nothing
so if you're really trying to like
there's people today they're like hey
man I'm still talking to people about a
movie it's dead guy business is dead as
of last [__] Thursday or something
yeah so for Cubans it starts the 17th
after the 17th you can't get a cube in
the focus because the 24th is debt
they start on the 20th and they get a
couple pigs and they [__] marinate
them oh first they keep them alive for
like two days and they feed them and
they make sure they [__] everything out
they [__] feed them and make sure
their insides around I don't know how
they do it remember hearing about this
as a child
and they stabbed a little pig
then they open them up then they [__]
stab them on and they rub mojo on them
every like an hour in the hour for like
22 [__] hours while they're drinking
doing blow
shifts
and once the 24th comes that pig is
[__] ready to go because he is a
crispy and [__] they got like two of
them his eyeballs are still in there
nice got that little red glaze on them
they tastes like a maritino cherry and
[__] that one of those dive bars wait
yeah eyeballs sure oh my god oh yeah you
ready to pick up unless you buy them
some of the pupil [__] shoots out
like a [__] rape seed tremendously
but you don't like cotton in your mouth
no I don't like cop in my mouth I don't
mind a chick pissing in my mouth either
but that's a completely different party
so I [__]
what we talking about I'm still
Christmas yeah me too let's put this
brownie I just did that with you Auntie
Dolores is getting that that
if you lived close to an auntie Dolores
store she sent me a box and I gotta tell
you something I've been stoned for the
last three weeks and that's just like
regular Stone like deep deep [__]
Stones I knew today was gonna be bad
because you called me like three or four
times and each time your voice
a lot of times
believe we're gonna [__] up tonight
I'm [__] them I just ate 230. oh my God
I was looking to get stoned I had to run
some errands this afternoon I knew
they're gonna be a pain in the [__]
ass I had to go sit and
Catch Air beans for like two [__]
people so I knew I just had and I
couldn't be stoned for them I couldn't I
had to give them the respect I love that
that's an errand to go catch an airplane
oh
the drive to know that you got to catch
your name first I lost my parking spot
I'm already pissed off you understand me
I'm not bothering nobody if I do
kettlebells all I gotta do is pull them
out of the truck I'm right there I gotta
walk to my house why don't you just put
the kettlebells in the road No One's
Gonna Steal kettlebells oh my road like
in your spot
that you put you stabbed people's tires
what's the difference the black apple
kettlebells on people run them over
they'll ruin their insides and [__] and
they'll ask who's kettlebells on that I
lose the kettlebells I like my
kettlebells I'll leave the kettlebells
alone all right I'm sorry well you
bought them with the [__] kettlebells
so you know you have that Christmas Eve
which is family after Christmas day and
you sit around and watch football and
eat the leftovers
it's considered a holiday between you
and I
do I give a [__]
do I I don't give a [__] yeah it's just
a day off that you're wasting my time I
could be getting some gears All About
the Benjamins this is every Jews because
these [__] Gentiles are sitting
around eating they could be flipping a
[__] Buck but they don't say nothing
they go to Long Island they do what the
[__] they need to do they take care they
mow the lawn whatever the [__] they do
but that's what it means is it important
well I think about my darkest times when
I spent Christmas Eve and a friends and
Christmas Day at a [__] bar watching
football making believe I was having a
good time was I miserable inside I was
broken inside you know I mean but you
bear with them I've said it here before
on the show and the best Christmases I
had was 87 when I was locked up
I thought it was going to be bad
and I turned out to be fantastic a bunch
of guys giggling laughing you know were
we smoking dope and drinking now we knew
what we stood we were just happy to be
doing that because they when you go to
prison they tell you you're not going to
do nothing yeah everybody else is eating
[__] [__] in that room
here we were in a room with [__]
shrimp and meatloaf and [__]
guacamole and tamales and [__]
burritos you know there's too many flags
in that kitchen though yeah it's [__]
tremendously it was just too much I
remember going back to my little bunker
into my room and going what the [__] was
that yeah so when you expect a bad
Christmas if you put a little effort
into it it might become a good [__]
Christmas
I've had Christmas as well I didn't have
a dollar in my [__] pocket
I had gel for my hair and
you know I went to somebody's house and
played it off and once and they're like
hey man we got an extra wallet for you
for Christmas and it just warms your
heart and it gives you a new outlook so
don't stay in the [__] house
Christmas day that's my whole thing
Christmas could be Christmas is what you
make of it if you stay in you're gonna
be bummed out about Christmas yeah even
people tell you they hate Christmas and
don't call the house and I'm gonna stay
alone and watch movies you're sitting
there like a [__] [__] you know yeah
it's about people it's about going out
in England and saying hello and you know
what it's that one time of the [__]
year do it for that who gives a [__]
about a Fourth of July people blowing
firecrackers and shooting guns nobody's
shooting guns Christmas [__] Eve you
know I should have done that I'm
terrible at going out right not
Christmas but two of my saddest uh New
Years I'm pretty sure I was in Boston
maybe one was out here I know definitely
one was in Boston and I had nothing to
do like no friends asked me to hang out
or something and I was watching
The Three Stooges marathon on AMC just
laying on my couch on my side New Year's
New Year's is completely different than
Christmas but it's like the same thing
two different you don't have to
I uh you know maybe he's pissed whatever
I'm dealing with like you know when time
he won't be pissed
so I give him a present Christmas Eve
not one with that Christmas Eve I
noticed my cousin the female is sitting
with the kids outside my cousin's okay
but I could tell there's always
something wrong with it she's got a
[__] husband a boyfriend that's a cop
and there's always something going on
it's like I finally couldn't take it I'm
like well you know Marta I came up here
to be with you and you're sitting the
[__] out here with you you know come on
in talk with us and I go eat something
and she's like well I might eat with my
husband whatever my boyfriend he ain't
[__] he's working eat some we're here
you know we're right in front of you
it's like when you go to get a
restaurant at somewhere you go to eat
pick up your order and there's a [__]
person taking your order right in front
of you put that [__] on hold
there's a live body with cash in front
of you right that's the guy you talked
to first it's the guy with cash in front
of you [__] who's on the phone if he
cared about his food he'd get his
[__] fat ass down here okay [__] that
[__] when you're doing customer
service you deal with who's in front of
you right [__] that homo on the [__]
phone I don't give a [__] about him this
lunch order probably one time this is
some [__] [__] up [__] anyway so I
that's the way I go Marty you're here
with your [__] Brothers your dad your
mom is here and you we're all in the
kitchen eating and you're you know so
she got mad at me because I said that do
I go [__] him come in here with us you
know and she got pissed off and we hung
out for another hour and a half I had a
good time with the baby and my cousins
you sure were playing music and the kids
and we were laughing my cousin's wife
and
on the way I go good night and my uncle
like raises his hand like [__] you and
and my cousin raises hell I am like [__]
you you know all right I get in the car
whatever I call them both the next day
and thanked them nobody called me back
and then last Thursday was the baby's
birthday that didn't say nothing I get
up the next morning I said my cousin
wrote something on Facebook
but that was it I called them back to
thank you for acknowledging never called
me back I called her back that night
never called me back I didn't even think
about it until yesterday or that
yesterday Saturday morning before the
Improv that oh my God
my cousin my uncle who's pretty tight
with the baby
didn't call and I go you know what
I'll tell you in my world I might have a
problem with you Lee but I'm still gonna
give Paul her Christmas present right
you know whatever's going on between me
and you that we'll put that aside it's
about her well I don't [__] am I not
going to be friends with her because you
want to be a [__] Momo so
I go you know what man this guy has no
idea
that I've never ever ever in my life
want to kill somebody as bad as I wanted
to kill my uncle for what he did to me
in 1984.
have you ever watched two fighters fight
and after the fight they beat the [__]
out of each other and they bleeding like
like what's his name kachek you know
he's got a glass [__] eye
you think when he sees GSB he wants to
hug him and jump up and down yeah they
fought and yeah you gotta act like a
[__] civilized so people don't talk
about it but deep down inside he's got a
[__] class out he hates GSP
that's how I feel yeah like we never
resolved that situation of what the [__]
he was thinking I was a 21 year old kid
you know
my circuitry was all [__] up Lee you
know I I had dropped my faith in society
I had dropped my faith in religion I was
done I was Donley
so I go you know what I know he'll help
me out I know he'll be cool with me my
uncle he was always there for me growing
up
you know I wasn't the best of person at
the time but it doesn't matter man
family's got to take you in you know
he didn't pick me up at the airport he
didn't answer his phone for days
I finally had to go to the restaurant
hunting down I remember sleeping out in
front of the restaurant spending the
whole night
sitting on [__] uh whatever Western
Boulevard whatever that is Vermont
Boulevard and all the way in hell down
there
and sleeping is fine in his restaurant
with a duffel bag getting up in the
morning the restaurant on me calling his
house spending quarters in those days
every time the answering machine picked
up you lost the 30 cents oh no for the
25 cents you know it was a [__] night
medley
finally shows up like a three with some
[__] chubby Mexican chick with a
smile on his face and he's like oh you
showed up huh
well I can't sleep but you can't sleep
in my house but you can sleep upstairs
he puts me in this liquor room with the
smell of mice and rats and
you know and then he started telling me
things that
I really didn't need to know at that age
like things about my mother and drugs
and how my mother got high when I was
inside of her and and just [__] that you
don't tell somebody and I'm like what
the [__] are you talking about you know
right
and telling me that I would never amount
to anything because of the blood blind I
came from
I'm like this is [__] cool all right
I don't our Hispanic parents a little
bit more straight I don't know if it's
straightforward or cool then like white
parents are or not I don't want to say
white but that world was a little bit
more they were more realistic I've
noticed it like it's not that they're
mean that I mean that sounds terrible
but it's like they don't pull punches
like white parents would never say some
of the stuff I've seen
so he told I didn't know this till after
I made up of them yeah because his kids
told me the story they're like when you
came to town that time he called the
house he wasn't living with us then but
he kept calling the house Tom was not to
answer the phone if you called
you know like this is my uncle this is
my blood you know if that's what I think
I'm about this I apologize to him 25
years later for my behavior but he's
never take me aside and say hey man I
was out of line that weekend too by the
things I said to you you know you
wouldn't amount to nothing that I mean
when I got on that plane after we drew
guns on each other
I got on that [__] plane to Jersey
you know once the smoke cleared I got
furiously
I had I I realized what it had done to
me I was furiously I think I wanted the
testicle Testaments I talk about how I
used to call him from prison yeah I'm
gonna kill you
and hang up on I mean this was going
back
until [__] I came out here I was kind
of scared and then I looked them up once
when I first moved in with Terry Terry
had a yellow pages and I looked at the
bar and I saw it was open I called him
from Terry's phone and the number had a
machine to it so I knew he still had the
bar
I was talking to Marilyn Martinez one
day like oh man where's Vermont
and she goes it's right there in
Hollywood why and I go my uncle has a
bar
at this number and she goes hold on I'll
ask David
and David her husband was black you know
he was from Crenshaw and she goes yeah
yeah there's a bar down there
a Mexican bar it's still there that's my
uncle and I remember going you know what
if I fail here
on the way out of town I'm gonna go and
hit him with a [__] two by four I hit
him I was dead seriously I was pissed
but Lee you get older
you know and you listen to people and
people always say to forgive
and it's like I forgive but I never
forgot I never really forgot them and
sometimes I'm meeting with them and I
want to bring it up like no what the
[__] were you thinking
you know at that time he had cheated on
his wife
with some chick
and then cheated on that chick with
another chick and gotten her pregnant
the third check the third check and the
kids around today
and the poor kid you know because of his
behavior the poor kid you could see the
kids [__] up too because the mother
didn't want the mother dropped him off
one day and said I don't want this
[__] kid oh no you know because it
was like uh she was a joke to the lover
you're not gonna be with me I don't want
this [__] kid I want the kid if we're
gonna be together type deal can you
imagine that no
so that's the hell he lives in you know
and uh I explained to my wife yesterday
my wife told me she goes you know what I
didn't really
understand the severity of what he had
done to you until yesterday it was it
was horridly horrid like how I went home
after three days and then I tried to
lash out yeah I tried the lash out and
Rob him put a pick a gun out on him
because I couldn't take what he was
saying to me anymore what if he said it
now like what if he had said it at this
age would it have affected you as much
no because I'm confident who I am I
already know who the [__] I am at that
age my dad had died at three my mom had
died at 16. I had an idea I I wasn't
[__] stupid you know what I'm saying
right but he said things I remember not
working and he's like so what do you
want to be a bartender he goes that's as
far as you ever get he goes if you're
lucky you you might make a good
bartender
can't see you doing anything else I said
well you know I might want to go to
school and be a lawyer because you can't
be a lawyer when you're a criminal
it's not in your blood type I mean he
just was saying
and at first I was like was like that
girl that's insecure that talks to a
pimp and a pentosa and I was like this
guy's [__] crazy he's not
he doesn't know anything about me
I just I'm on coke and I I had a bad run
a life and I'm gonna get this you know
and I left there and the whole point of
getting
I think in 84 the whole point of getting
out of that [__] rocket ship was to
get my [__] together go put a bullet in
his [__] head
that was the plan the whole time but
then over the do you think any of it is
he was just trying to motivate you like
did anything
there's a way to motivate people there's
a way to talk to somebody with love
there's a way to talk to somebody [__]
up and then reeling back with love he
just talked to me [__] up there was no
love there was nothing you know
sometimes your daddy Gonna Leave You
gotta do this you know and you feel bad
and he goes I'm telling you this is
going to be your dad I love you
and on the way to the car you go you
know what I can't because he's talking
to me from the heart this guy said
nothing from the heart the only thing he
threw at me from the heart was hate
anger and this you know resentment and
then the other thing there was more of
that story my mother had given him money
this is what really shocked me because I
was [__] up on drugs it was five years
later but my mother had given him a ton
of money before she died
I don't know what the terms were or
whatever
so I thought when I would come out and
he'd go hey man your mom gave me money
before she died she gave me 20 000. he's
five
get your life together I wouldn't have
complained Lee
I wouldn't have said anything
he didn't even make that effort you know
so it was just a it was just a [__] up
time I'm gonna you know I gotta talk
about revenge I love Revenge I I've
always loved when Hari first called me
with the [__] story I thought about
when I was a kid one night this buddy of
mine got hit
and uh the guy was a lot older than him
we were probably 16 17 and this guy was
in his 20s I remember him from being
like a freshman in high school he was a
lot older than I was and he was always a
[__] but he dated
a friend like a girl that I knew and she
was young like she was like a sophomore
and he was like a sophomore in college
probably you know we were probably
juniors in high school and this guy hit
a friend of mine like oh bro it would be
my honor let's get back at this guy
regardless of the win whatever comes
back from him right and we uh set up
this thing and the guy came out we hit
him with a wiffle ball bat with rocks in
it oh we got a ruffle ball bat we cut it
we put rocks in and then you put a big
rock at the end so the Rocks don't come
out you throw a little dirt in that
[__] you have no idea how hard
it was about bad hurts when it's at the
Rocks it would probably hurt empty yeah
it burns empty yeah it burns empty you
get hit with a Riverboat by 15 times in
the neck or somewhere the Skin's exposed
I just imagine on the back like but with
rocks in it oh my God
and that was my favorite Revenge story
I've always I've always daydreamed about
revenge I I don't think I ever the only
thing I ever did was this freaking
[__] in high school was pushing me
around he was younger than I was but he
was bigger because I was small
and one day he was messing with me in
the gym locker room I don't remember
exactly what he was doing but I had
enough and I was like I think I was like
a junior or senior and I just slammed
him against some lockers and he we
started it was like the only real fight
I've ever been in we don't think any
punches were even thrown I just remember
slamming his head against some lockers
and I got suspended for a day but I was
so my mom wasn't even mad no I was so
happy it was the only time I ever did it
you stuck up for yourself it's weird
that people think revenge is
revenge is like for me Revenge isn't
just about that it's like when like
somebody will go hey man [__] uh
you know somebody will say to me you
know what uh you should make me your
partner I don't really think Lee's a
good partner for you and I go okay and
then the podcast will win an award
yeah and I'll see that person well come
here for a second that's Revenge to me
yeah that was always my big Revenge I
feel that way now for like people who
were mean to me in high school and I I
go onto Facebook and they're they're
still working at the high school gym
which is fine but a little bit I feel
like yeah take that [__] yeah like a
couple of them have hit me up like they
come out to L.A and like we should hang
out I'm like we were never friends in
high school why why am I gonna drive all
the way to Los Feliz to see you now I'm
[__] no parking right you know
revenge like for me with my ex-wife I
really want but but I knew that
if I snuck around and did well
that would hurt her more
you know she wanted me to either end up
dead disappear or go to prison
because I would never have contact right
with them again
but I kept that and for me that was my
revenge it was succeeding at something
so the revenge is also something like
that you know yeah somebody fires and
says you're [__] an idiot really I'm
gonna go over to your competitor and
watch what I do over there
[Music]
all right